good night gamers you thought i was done
with minecraft
no never done with minecraft i have so
much
to show you guys it's even more pathetic
than before where do i start i beat the
game and i thought i would be done
they just sparked a whole new uh spark
in me isn't that right
sparky funky first of all
i have the soul walker now so now i go
fast wait we're not even started yet
watch while i get the enchantment there
it is
let's go if i want to go anywhere
look at this [ __ ] monkey look how
[ __ ] fast i am
uh that's cool that's cool i didn't know
you could do that
so i had it around the base too and oh
my god
i am easily entertained shut up it's
cool oh i want to go to this part of the
base
no problem kill a spider
i know i'm supposed to wait for the
sword i was just meaning but yeah
it's the bomb okay first of all we're
gonna do a raid today just so you know i
just want to show off my
base really quick so i made it like this
it's pretty smart i i think it's pretty
smart because you can't automate
in other words you can yes you can
your character still has to be active
it's not like the melon form that is
completely
independent right so what i did is i did
it like this
i use my own pick to get the stuff
right and as you can see they go through
the floor
at least they're supposed to oh god
where's bro it's working
is it full are they full they might be
full actually yeah they go through they
go through it's just a little slow
they basically they go directly back
into the system there's nothing more to
it
i i thought it was pretty smart because
i still catch some of them
and then i can just plant them from here
pretty easily
and it's just the same on the other side
obviously it's not perfect but
i was quite happy with it so they're
collecting underneath it goes back
can we see actually yeah see it goes up
which is pretty neat it's pretty neat my
base is
insanely laggy now
[Laughter]
uh what else is new oh shulker boxes
these things are amazing
so what they do is that you can fill the
shulker bugs
up then pick it up and bam
it's a portable uh chest basically which
is so
freaking good so that made it so i can
start farming materials
way easier like the soul sand and the
coolest part about it
is that okay let's say i had a big uh i
gathered a bunch of cobblestone or some
[ __ ] right
all right look look how much cobblestone
i have in my shulker box
oh it's gonna be so no actually let's do
it like this we have a bunch of mixed
stuff
right uh yeah some arrows they will go
in the system torches will go in the
system
uh fire go in the system too okay oh
that's so annoying now i have to like
go to all the spots to pick it out
no no no not if you have an automated
minecraft system so i just placed them
here
let's say they were all full i placed
them all there
i hit the switch they tick in
and then they tick out through the
system baby
get sorted my dudes yes
why are the melons disappearing there no
they're not they're still going okay
good
but the sand is going in
the sand is going in it's all going in
it makes my computer lag oh god they
spawn on top
get off my wall
don't look at me while i murdered you
there you go
moving come on i'm gonna get you
oh yeah we can just leave them there to
do the job
it's pretty cool i love shulker boxes
now i had a problem where
uh if i remove the shulker boxes the
shulker box itself would go in the
hopper and then get sorted
so i have i have a way to just turn it
off if i want to but we don't have to
worry about that right now
shulker boxes are amazing they're so
good
i can't believe i never used them cool
part about it too they go on walls and
stuff like that i don't know if that's
cool
but like i didn't feel like putting it
back and i know i'm gonna need it later
so i just kept it there
uh anyway let's do the raid okay
i'm gonna warn you guys before you judge
me i've been playing a lot
like a lot lot like i'm more than i've
ever played
but if we head over here
we have my self-designed farm
i mean it's not really i mean i used the
basic
template from mr cat's
raid farm but basically here is my
self-made
i'll call it that i don't care hillary
farm
wait what's happening
i thought i was going to die didn't you
what's hitting him
they're fine why aren't they spawning
there they go
they were all in the system already look
at them go
i love it so much yes yes yes
let's go i love it so much it's so funny
uh so yeah they dropped down here
and then i can just kill them get the
bad omen
so we can start a raid damn it's really
effective
i'm i'm pretty damn pleased is this too
much for my computer
playing minecraft and recording my face
cam at the same time like damn
uh took a lot to cover up but it did
make it more effective
so they all spawn inside you can see
them in the shadow
[Music]
here they come
i love this [ __ ] it's so cool it's not
great for xp
uh but it is pretty good for just
getting the omen
and a little bit xp and money i would
say it's mainly just fun to watch them
i get a lot of joy out of this i think
this is one of my favorite
now obviously i gotta have a
self-sorting system underneath
that is working really well as you can
tell
it's exactly how i want it uh let me
show you
how it works oh my god stop spawning
it is a bit dangerous i've died from my
own traps before but
we should be all right so basically they
go down here
and then on this floor they go down here
i mean i don't think about it i probably
don't need the floor in between
and then they get sucked in there which
then goes to the elevator
this feels a bit dangerous i'm actually
gonna get out of here
how do i do this without dying
oh god i'm gonna die why did i go down
here
oh actually it's all right i can go
through the system now i think about it
it should be fine this is a little
dangerous but hey as long as i don't
fall off the edge at the top
i should be all right
this will be the dumbest death of all
time if i die here
yeah i'm okay i'm okay am i okay i don't
know am i okay i don't
hold up am i dying
this is it it's not even worth it's not
even
i make it out here there we go
[Music]
i'm fine i'm fine guys
i'm fine i'm completely fine how the
[ __ ] have i made it this far
i'm fine
[Music]
i have the lighter on me
oh god i can't go back to base i have
the omen so here's my raid farm this is
from mr cat
yeah another great tutorial oh i also
want to give a shout out to waddles
i saw you comment on my video and then i
realized he's the channel i forgot
because i got the iron form from him uh
yeah just chat he was watching the
series i appreciate you
but yeah the raid the raid stars they
always spawn over there
i i'm scared of covering up too much
because uh
i'm scaring i'm just gonna block all the
spawns
but it basically works the exact same
way there's a villager
uh inside the walls that they are trying
to go to but they get sucked into the
system
and here is my raid farm
which is super cool
it feels like this is illegal or
something i mean a lot of people told me
i should make a raid farm
but uh yeah it feels a bit like you're
cheesing it
but it's amazing for getting totems of
undying
i like to spy on them a little there you
go
idiots you're all going to die dumbasses
[Music]
going go go in the system just go in the
system bro
get systemized [ __ ] just go into my
automatic system [ __ ] you're all going
to my automatic system
[Applause]
i actually almost died while using this
because they do spawn the
evokers i think they're called which is
the one that spawned a little flying
fairies and they do a [ __ ] ton of damage
um and they can they can clip through
the wall so you gotta be a little bit
careful
and those horse things die from the lava
that's basically how they work anyway i
ain't got time fellas
see you in the system
you can actually see them spawn too
which is kind of cool
did they just spawn on no they didn't oh
look they're just going in
idiots they're like where did he go dumb
asses
i got your knees boy get all their knees
you might be wondering hey felix why did
you spend all this time setting this up
you already beat the game what's the
point
well what's the point of anything really
is it not to have fun
isn't that the point of video games
because i'm having fun doing it i think
it's awesome
[Music]
they look so dumb oh they heard me
i wish there was a way i could connect
this sorting system with my
the base at home that'd be so [ __ ]
cool but
the chunks need to be loaded and they're
too far away
my dream i want to expand the base as
much as humanly possible man
i think there's one more wave and then
we'll do a proper wave
we'll see them spawn now i think there
they are
they come out of nothing because they
can't spawn on the mountain
i made sure that [ __ ] oh god
[Music]
is it lagging less now a little bit all
right i think the line we're waiting for
the last one
hello ah geez don't tell me you get
stuck
somewhere we saw them all spawn right
oh it's oh god that's not good that's
actually really bad
[Music]
oh sometimes my shader makes him
invisible no he's still missing
where the [ __ ] is he i'm scared of
looking down because i could actually
fall in and die
no oh that's so annoying i don't get the
award
i don't know how to fix that i mean
maybe he's spawned in a cave or
something
that's a bit anticlimactic anyway we do
get the tournament of undying
only one apparently all right let's head
back to
the not you
maybe there's too many entities at night
and that messes it up
[Music]
why is literally nothing spawning is my
render distance too long
there we go yeah look they spawn in they
turn around they go right in the system
hell yeah hell yeah it looks so cool
too i wish i was using black stone
cobblestone's so ugly but
what are you gonna do oh they're already
here pardon me
didn't see you walk in all right so we
got the bad omen right away nice
so what happens if i go back to the raid
farm then there's still one remaining
where where are thou i don't see where
they could possibly have gone
is this a common thing found them
got them are they in the water i don't
ah where are they what's going on
could they be in this hole i hear him
i found you [ __ ] he fell in the hole
oh god it started i started another rain
[ __ ]
oh god [ __ ] this
i don't think so i don't think so
guys i'm just gonna go in the hole i'll
see you down there
see this is why you need to remember to
take up the electric god damn
oh yes last one
oh there's one more way or did i i
started another
i started another did i i can't tell
ah geez they are dangerous
[ __ ] your legs [ __ ] see it their thing
the bar is going down because their um
horse looking thing is going in the lava
[Music]
we're missing two oh we're missing one
oh all right there we go
and that's how you raid hard mode
hardcore style oh let me get that money
oh nice
oh okay here's where the [ __ ] tones
were
jesus christ that's not from one that's
not from one
i've done a lot of these i actually have
way more at home i'll show you guys
i think i have them here
oh yep
we're uh we're getting a bit full on the
babies
if i ever die by not having a totem of
undying
then i will die in real life because
that's the dumbest [ __ ] ever i have so
many
oh man i missed one
all right for the last time let's wait
for them to come in
man i don't deserve to live all right so
let's get the bad omen again
there we go we got the bad omen and
let's go
back you like the arrows i made because
i kept getting lost
flying with the election
let's do a raid at our own house
i'm a little nervous i just think it
would be cool i
i it just feels lame to do a normal
rain we gotta defend our fire nation
industrial revolution minecraft temple
we gotta defend the bonkey and watercat
i hear them coming in from the east
there they are
i don't know what's a good way to do
this
oh they saw me
they're trying you're all going into my
automatic sorting system you understand
me
easy peasy uh the last two i assume
they're down by the villagers
yeah hello
[Music]
thank you stay away from my farmers
don't worry i protect you i protect you
by almost shooting at you
oh it's getting dark now dark and
dramatic
monkey i ride with bonky this will be
glorious
we ride to battle this is just like lord
of the rings don't shoot monkey
idiot you hit bonky you die
bucky bunky pewdiepie do it too strong
let's go this is so badass
hey don't hit bonkey don't hit funky
we had a deal you can kill me but don't
kill my donkey okay
i hear them of the trash
okay when the ravanger or whatever they
call come i think that's when i want to
be a little careful
where the hell are they oh
it's always concerning when you don't
see them
i have pushback on my bow so i should be
okay
knockback whatever
[Music]
yeah let's go too easy
all right we're missing one but where ah
found him
wait why that was not it oh god
don't you dare go near my villagers
[ __ ]
don't be scared i will protect you
you may be locked in there forever and
want to die but don't worry i'll keep
you alive
that's a pewdiepie promise
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa whoa don't want to mess
with these guys
oh there's a witch as well
i don't think so oh god she poisoned me
why do i have a healing bug did she give
me that
oh i just realized i can change the
beacons of course
oh they spawn on top of it what maybe
that buy me some time hold up
i forgot i can change the beacons
obviously i want to make them
uh there's a comet one right oh my god
the poison is so annoying get down from
there
stop oh i gotta break the glass then
that's a little that way i don't know of
course
uh all right so strength right
oh that's sick strength two
no okay now we do way more damage oh my
god
hey get up my property
ah keep thinking he's gonna move
oh my gosh just stop
oh my god
got him all right let's say hi to our
friends
i have sharpness right i should be okay
oh am i interrupting something he's ckc
boys
do i one shot them he had it oh god oh
god that's an invoker
all right we got him this is [ __ ]
weird
i'm walking so fast
[Music]
god i hate i hate these
got him got him
oh another one
gotta defend my base at all costs you
know where the hell did they oh my gosh
guys you're terrible at this
dude i'm on point he's trying to
infiltrate the meatball
stop him
another album cover shot coming up
ha ha i can't fight
you can't fight and you can't hide and
run either
okay damn this is fun why did i build a
raid farm this is way cooler just
fighting them right right bunkie monkey
album cover in three two one
boom that looks sick nice okay actually
i need to
oh dramatic drama
are they attacking you
stop him where's my sword
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
let's cool it let's cool it
okay why oh buggy i'm sorry
where's my sword
there we go
don't think so just
they're shooting them no
i'm sorry i was supposed to protect you
i knew there was a chance for that i was
i was ready to face the consequences
this is so [ __ ] anime dude i'm living
in anime right now
let's go last wave oh they're all stuck
nice
oh god i'm out of arrows
i was hoping that wouldn't happen
that poison is hurting dude oh god
they're all there
it's better to snipe them before they
summon their
those first this is bad i'm really low
jesus christ i think i might have to
just
do that bro
it's intense dude i love it
give me the baby all right but we're
lucky with the sponsor these guys
no no no
[Music]
[Applause]
we did it that's it it's not to kill
these
whoa there's fireworks
where oh they're shooting fireworks oh
they're so happy
hey they love me i knew they loved me
i didn't know that that's so cool i'm
almost dying
all right so maybe doing it in your base
isn't the best idea but it is fun i'll
tell you that
god damn more babies
so now we get the hero the village buff
and i'm sure as you all know we get
better trading now unfortunately we lost
one of our villagers
and the second one i didn't like him
anyway so it's okay i do like you
no i wanted you to die [ __ ] all right
i've been meaning to kill him for so
long it's so useless
uh the prices are better by quite a lot
actually damn
yeah more money
all right let's look at the damage not
bad not bad
at all
yes dude i i want to get
a whole box filled with emerald blocks
we're getting there i mean it's still a
way to go but that would be [ __ ]
sick dude then i would feel like i'm
truly rich
but yeah minecraft veteran
saying thank you for watching this
series i'll probably
do updates every once in a while i still
love playing the game but obviously
uh whatever i do from here will just be
random stuff to improve the base so
don't expect them too often at least but
i do i will keep it up if i feel like it
uh so yeah thanks for watching guys
leave a like subscribe
every subscriber i get another
subscriber see you tomorrow with
whatever
i upload bye bye